I thank you guys for coming out tonight
this is the complete semi Slav part five
so we got some people that have been
here before we got some new faces which
is cool was your name by the way Daniel
okay how good are you at chess not good
okay that's fine so you are starting on
part five but as always it's you can
always jump in at any point during this
series here so we are looking at the
semi Slav so we've already covered this
so we're going to skip to the part we're
at now we're still looking at the e3
lines next week we will begin our
coverage of the Bishop to g5 lines those
are very exciting but for now we're
still looking at Queen c2 again we're
just making a useful waiting move the
alternative is Bishop to d3 in which
we've had a look at before but this does
allow black to take here and play d5
with tempo so that explains the move
Queen to c2 just a useful waiting move
and now it doesn't make sense for black
to take here so black needs to find a
useful developing move Bishop to d6 and
last week we reached this position and
we covered the main line which is Bishop
to d3 and we also have a look at the
move b3 just protecting the pond but
tonight we're going to look at a very
fascinating very aggressive move I
teased you guys with it a little bit
last week
g4 yeah I see some some heads turning
you played this with which side were you
you were white and you played this
alright awesome did you know lots of
theory you do a little bit all right
that's good so yeah maybe you'll be able
to help us out here this is the shear of
shambhala
attack so both of them known for their
you know kind of crazy aggressive styles
so it makes sense that shear off who
played it first you know you know it's
2700 so something that he came up with
and a cheval of also has helped
popularize it playing it doesn't the
time
Wow g4 right I mean that's if you've
never seen this before once you hate to
run into this in a tournament your
opponent's just like g4 and you know if
that is a big surprise to you things can
go downhill rather quickly now
surprisingly there's actually four moves
in this position that are played quite
frequently two of them have been played
about 1200 times each it's I think on
databases like exactly the same and the
other two have been played about 600
times each so there's two really popular
moves and two less popular moves but I
guess my first question and I do want to
get the audience involved because we got
a good crowd here tonight my question is
what are the four moves yeah one is
Knight takes g4 for sure yeah
castles is actually not a very popular
move if you cancel it allows me to just
play g5 and I think actually was a
cheer-off game where this happened and
well that's not a very good square and
you can go back here and then I believe
those a game was sheer off where he just
simply went here and he castled I don't
know it's not really where you you want
your knight and it's white is actually
about to open up the center he plays
Bishop d2 castles and he plays
immediately the movie four and this
Knight actually can end up offsides
especially if you know I can put my
bishop here it's sort of a weird square
for the knight because it's it's not
really easy to come back into the game
trying to think of whose opponent was
because there's a really good game where
somebody cancelled but you don't want to
actually castle into this attack the
White has here so we've we've come up
with one move though yeah h6 this is one
of the moves sure just renting g5 C 5 C
5 is not a move I sue it just like g5
yes let's actually not a move I think
this is just sort of the same deal here
I'll display g5 again you can go to h5
but yeah so we do have to really be
worried we don't really want white to
play g5 and we have to put a knight on
the side or put our night on e 8 or or
somewhere we don't really want to go so
all of the moves do have something to do
with anticipating to move g5 by white
yeah
g5 the super counter Arjun gambit with
maximal confusion and actually I did
look at this that's what's funny is
you're not the first person to say this
but what has a really really strong move
you ready to be shocked also how do I
know this it's crazy Age 4
okay page five actually somebody did
this it was like a month ago but
actually nobody's ever done this but
somehow still prepared here and then the
computer said like whites winning do you
agree yet kind of so I think you have to
take on g4 and I played Bishop h3 yes I
think like this I've looked at and then
II for might also be a thing but I'm
threatening to take your knight and then
take it rook yeah you see I'm gonna keep
going
yeah wits yeah what's at least better um
yeah g5 not a move unsurprisingly yeah
so the other ones I think are a little
bit harder to find or ninety-four just a
gambit here and you want to do this and
in this line actually I mean I doubt
this you know is very good here in this
line though actually you do sacrifice
pawns as both colors quite frequently
especially when you just get more active
pieces we're going to notice that a lot
of these lines what really matters is
peace activity more than material so
there's gonna be lots of sacrifices in
these lines and okay maybe you can play
a move like 'if I've maybe this is your
whole point but I'm not really buying
the whole sacrifice here so just going
back here I'll go ahead and give these
away now well one of them is to take on
the c4
which may seem anti positional you know
giving away a center pond for a side
pond what's the deal there and you're
maybe helping my my development I'll
just take back with my bishop on c4 but
you are giving your knight access to d5
so in lines like this if you take and
they played g5 you can put your knight
on d5 and so we will actually have a
look at that the other move is Bishop to
b4 so you're painting it so now if g5
you can play 94 that's the idea and I
have another question for the class to
which there's two popular moves and
less popular moves can you guys put them
in there in the right category so which
two are the popular ones in which two
are the the unpopular ones might
surprise you oh yeah
and so that's why I assume that's what
most people would think but surprisingly
night takes g4 not a very popular move
it's in the bottom of popularity
I think Bishop before it might be truly
the least common but Knight takes
actually a very unpopular move which is
kind of surprising normally when there's
a game but you take it but it's not
really a gambit so the two main moves
are taking on c4 and h6 which have been
played like one of them was played like
with one game more according to chess
base but let's go ahead and let's just
start here with this I think this is a
good way to start and it's not even
really a true gambit so it's called The
Share Option ball of attack not this
year of the ball up gambit even though
everybody will always a call of the
problems in these lines and so we reach
this position and this was the point I
played g4 so that if you take it I play
rook g1 and we're going to look at it
from whites point of view tonight just
because if you're clicking on this maybe
you want to see it from my point of view
so for something different we're looking
at it from White's point-of-view tonight
and there's two moves here the most
popular move is to take on h2 I think
that you know you want a pond that's
very good I'm going to take back on g7
so we're going to look at this four
sequence in a minute however I do want
to mention this uh this other tricky
move here Queen to f6 and this one I
like in particular because once I played
somebody rated about 400 points higher
rated than me and he thought he would
surprise me with g4 but I had this Queen
f6 line prepared so it's not a very
popular move but I don't think it's bad
at all and we're actually going to see a
game between mom and Aarav and Anand
that was playing 2013 that I knew of at
the time and well it's just a very good
game and it was a quick miniature so
we'll have a look at that but what's
funny is when I played this I was losing
like the whole game but that didn't
matter because for the whole game both
me and my
opponent thought I was winning and in
chess sometimes that's you know more
important just thinking that you're
winning so we both thought I was winning
and then so I was very confident sitting
at the board confidently and then I went
on to win so I something funny that just
bringing that attitude to the chess
board actually can result in a lot of
wins do you have that you have that
attitude that you're just you know I'm
talking about yeah you know I'm talking
about when you just bring that ferocious
attitude that you're going to be able to
win so yeah even though it wasn't wasn't
well-founded I we both thought I was
winning and then that was the result
okay so after they take here we're gonna
look at this a non game so a non Ted
black in this position and now rotates
g7 okay so material is equal and what's
nice about this line rather than the
main line is this queen is actually a
little bit annoying on f3 I don't know
how much white really enjoys that
so after Knight to f6 another idea is to
go to f8 and try to go to g6
because then you trap the rook and you
can play King update and take the rook
so that's one other line but we're just
going to look at Knight to f6 this is
what was a non-story centralizing a
piece how could that be wrong and now
Bishop to d2 and this is already a
mistake though it's which is sort of
surprising the main move is ripped to g5
which is a very sneaky move if I do
nothing
what was White's threat let's see if we
can understand rook to g5 I think this
is a tricky move yeah were you just
trying to stop me from playing a5 or
Wilson
Arjuna Bishop g2 this will trap the
Queen yeah so very sneaky move so
instead you know the Queen a lot to move
like Queen h1 would be played but in
this game Bishop d2 was playing hmm and
it's that's super obvious how the fact
that you just blocked this could
actually be an issue at all I hear
Knight to g4 with some rather annoying
pressure on f2 and h2 and if I remember
that the computer actually wants you to
just sack the exchange because it's
already that bad
so flack already has a very dominant
position in the game night d1 okay it's
not the dream move that you wanted to
play in this position okay took on each
two this is also sort of a mistake I
think but so yeah I haven't looked at
this file in like a month
but we'll try to remember some things
but in this position now not trading but
rook g8 with in all sorts of annoying
pressure down the G file so he went here
and I think there's there's lots of good
moves
rook g1 was also totally crushing he
went here and this is funny too let's
see was it here yeah so it's here
so you went here this is the only
blemish on the game black actually had
an amazing tactic you can pause at home
I'm just going to give it away for the
live audience but he could have blade
Knight takes check okay so we take back
right now is it
it's not here like I think I go here and
then if you save the sky I have an
amazing move
so if yes up here
so there was that you know amazing
combination that could have been played
I get one here this is also totally
winning I'm trying to get through a lot
of games today so we're not going to
spend too much time on anyone yeah good
move and he took here which was a
mistake because now here and here I'm
going to checkmate you Ani - you can
take my stuff and here okay the checks
are going to run out no matter what you
do so Whitehead resigned
instead of doing maybe this and your
checks quickly run out yeah so a very
fast win for black and there's a lot of
really short games even at you know top
level two very top-notch players in that
position so you can kind of see just how
fast you can actually go over long in a
position like this okay let's have one
more run through this position so Queen
f6 is a very interesting move more
popular is here another sort of a four
sequence after we trade they can take on
g7 and we're going to follow now the
game between Richard report and Pavel
Eliana
from Beale 2015
so yeah report known for his very
imaginative entertaining style is
playing another very strong player
there's one of the club mates favorite
players here one thing
okay so blacks up a pawn but it is the
h7 pawn and black actually has to be
kind of worried because he's a long way
from having his a safe King for example
we have to get all of these piece all
these pieces out of the way before we
can think of castling and otherwise
we're just going to stay in the center
and white for his part well most
commonly I can play Bishop d2 castle and
efore and start doing stuff in the
center and kind of like how in the Banco
gambit when your opponent has a pond
like this they can sometimes actually
get stuck defending their extra pawn so
maybe in the future if I can bring this
rook over somewhere over here I can get
lots of pressure on the Kings side so
these are the kinds of things that White
is looking to do he did give up a pawn
but I'm going to develop really fast I'm
gonna play e4 and open the center and
I'm going to get at your king before you
can castle that's that's his plan at
least okay in the game night to f8 and
it is also worth noting that as white
white is thinking about playing a move
like f4 because then you know your
bishop is a little trapped so if instead
here you actually run into some problems
so you do have to be careful this is a
constant idea so instead he went to f8
maybe I'll play Knight to g6 and so it's
anyone here so again yeah so if here now
I can just go here actually I think I
touched this guy in first so something
like this is definitely fine for black
so instead what can you to was played
kicking the bishop back and E for more
comment again again is Bishop d2 and
castling but you went for it right away
zai alright we'll just open it up like
g6
and now Bishop g5 it's not very easy to
move the Queen away because if the Queen
goes anywhere then Bishop f6 could be a
little bit annoying it's a good square
for a bishop so he went back and now
sort of a surprising decision but first
I'll ask in this type of structure who
wants to trade the dark squared bishop
s' just in general
positional terms what is why does
everyone say in white
why does white want to trade the dark
square bishop Yeah right
yeah because it's there's all these dark
squares that you know could be very weak
if we end up trading these are scored
bishops so most commonly in this types
of position people will actually trade
the bishops here so a very surprising
controversial decision excuse me
Bishop to e3 and perhaps he's thinking
well I'm going to do the attacking I get
the center and I'm going to open it up
and you still have to move some pieces
out of the way if you want to castle to
safety so I can still castle own then I
can take a lot of stuff in the center so
maybe he's thinking well I'm going to
use my bishop because I'm going to
attack I don't want to trade pieces all
right so here and here he actually makes
another interesting decision so black
just took upon so you could consider
recapturing it but he plays a little bit
more provocatively he just castles so
ice actually made some sort of
interesting decisions he didn't trade
the bishops he didn't take the pawn back
so black says I'll keep it now I'm two
pawns up no and so white has to
demonstrate his ability to open the
center to get some attack going to get
some sort of compensation here in the
game it just never really happened
d5 that's a good start but now Queen a5
I mean
Bishop g7 I'm going to castle so yeah
you got to play d5 but you know what are
you what's your plan now that's a good
pun yeah but it is two pawns
Queenie five and now white play is a
very interesting move I think it might
even be the best move but White's
position is actually pretty bad you're
down two pawns and if you less you
actually have something here and perhaps
he he doesn't just based on the game you
know I can be in trouble so I think he
was a little bit too imaginative for for
his own good he was too clever by half
ninth to b5 which in itself is a very
good move the point is if you take
Bishop c3 and then you got some problems
on this diagonal but he just went to
have seven no everything's fine
the knight one here and so if we have a
look now okay I'm still two pawns up
well this looks like a nice pawn kind of
but how is it ever going to go forward
the knight is right way in blacks
territory but it's stuck there what is
it really doing so there's really not a
whole lot the white can claim as a big
advantage here and you know these are
some top players so the side with more
pawns ended up winning so we'll just
show a few more moves here so very funny
way to trade and here what actually
resigned well I think it's a technically
lost position and you know these guys
are pros but if for example here I think
black maybe would have just simply gone
here or the more entertaining way he
could have gone to h3 and then wherever
this rook goes he sort of controls the
entire board and White's pieces are
stuck so black will slowly win this
position and so I'm white in this game I
think he just he tried to be a little
bit too clever
is sort of the thing that you want to
happen but you gave away too many pawns
and he didn't raid those bishops right
away it actually got him into a lot of
trouble so that was one interesting game
okay let's have a look at another move
which one should we look at yeah
Bishop b4 okay
which is probably the least popular but
some very strong players have played it
so we're actually gonna look at a game
now between gelfand and Kramnik that was
played in 1996 so it was a while back
that this game was played but again the
point is if g5 now we can go here and we
can bring our Queen in and we can get
lots of pressure on c3
that's that's the main idea okay so
instead Bishop d2 was played so now
again I'm thinking about playing a move
like g5 Queen e7
in a three so I'm going to try to win
the bishop pair so in this game okay
so you've won the bishop pair which is
you know which is a very fair
accomplishment
but what's interesting is is now move
like this I'm going to play Bishop to a6
at some moment maybe I can play a move
like a 5 maybe mine I can go to e4 maybe
I maybe I will end up castling this way
if I'm allowed because without this
night here you know sometimes if if g5 I
actually have this square for my knight
so I'm actually might be able to castle
born here and it's interesting to see
just who gets their pieces developed
faster in this particular line because
now we see some very something very
interesting after Queen to a4 just
attacking the bishop like took on c4
with a pond so we get this fancy way of
training and in a position like this
we're kind of wishing you know we hadn't
played g4 because now this position
would be sort of a semi normal position
except for you know we create a
weaknesses for some reason and blacks
going to play C 5 or a5 he's going to
Castle and you know everything's fine so
castles g5 so notice now that we
protected this maybe maybe we're
thinking about taking it so g5 95
um and yes I don't think white got
anything special out of the opening and
it remains to be seen where he's going
to put his king now f5 and okay maybe it
may be stronger was c5 or a5 in a g5 is
pretty strong move here but this also is
a pretty strong move just making sure
you keep the Kings side closed notice if
here I will take back with my queen
which would be really good for black
okay so instead he Castle long so we get
an opposite side canceling situation
which is actually quite common in these
sorts of lines c5 black should open the
C file can go in now we want to do stuff
on that side of the board b5 sacrificing
upon and it's it's difficult for white
because it's hard to take it and it's
hard not to take it as if you don't take
it I mean I can play moves like c4 b4
and I'm going to be my attack seems to
be a lot faster White's attack hasn't
really started over here in the game he
didn't take it so now I can use the B
file and in the game black went on to
you know masterfully attack his opponent
would be three ging a two so it doubles
up and white is stuck passively
defending and now black found a really
strong continuation b5 just breaking in
the center also maybe I can put my Queen
on this diagonal which would be kind of
scary for wait so here black has a big
attack and white hasn't gotten anything
going
so yeah we just line up our queen with
our king can got out of that diagonal
but everything here really favors black
he took
and this position is quite bad for white
but here he sort of compounded his his
misery here by taking on c5 and this is
in fact definitely losing now however
you may want to pause your videos at
home can you actually see the the
victory from here so there's a very nice
combination you have to find some only
moves and well we'll test the audience
here so I think this is a little bit
tougher so I do want to give you guys a
little bit of time so go ahead and think
about this for a couple minutes and all
I'll see what you guys come up with here
if you get an idea okay
it takes rook yeah and well in the game
he took here what happens if I take here
this is sort of the idea this also is a
move to be considered probably more than
one move here
yeah even idea takes on d6 it's black to
move
Queen d6 yeah I think this is fine and
this you know this just looks really
good because if here you're not going to
be happy I think I can just go back I
can take this all right I mean I can
just probably just go back this I can
take the Queen to yeah I was wondering
if this is stronger but okay taking the
Queen should be enough so yeah if I
can't calculate this winning then I
guess I take your queen but this looks
really winning it to you taking the
Queen is better yeah but only if this if
this leads to meat then you should play
this it would be so you know you'd have
to take your time but it's worth it's
worth thinking about otherwise this also
just totally wins so for that reason in
this position here you take on c5
welcome to the class
and here's the move that you have to see
as black again there's only one move so
hopefully you guys saw this position and
then you found this brilliant move
because without this move you really
have nothing all right Knight c3 so you
have to rhyme your name again Daniel all
right yeah Daniel's on the ball okay uh
well I can't really take it either way
so he went here now did we see that the
finish
it takes a three it's suggested but I
will take back obviously I can't take
with my poem so I'll take with my queen
I don't really see your follow up here
because I'm on your night and your queen
so not quite you want to play Queen see
five what do you say if whites Queen
wasn't on c5 what takes me to yeah again
excellent and the game he took back
everything else loses
all right how old are you you're eight
yeah so so easy even an 8 year old could
see it so white resigned have you two
played eachother no okay okay but the
obvious point for anybody interested is
here checkmate
so a fantastic combination from this
position after the rook takes well I
just had to calculate and you know good
job for our audience we got a really
strong audience tonight and we were able
to figure out all of these tactics in 93
a very fun move to be able to play and
then okay obviously to sack your queen
to finish them off is a very nice way to
finish any game all right so we'll go
back okay so we're returning to this
position so if you're just joining us
this is the position we're starting at
tonight and there's two moves we haven't
talked about yeah you want to pick one
h6 and this is sort of becoming the more
popular way to play solo for time I
guess we're gonna have to sort of zoom
through this game but I want to show a
game that was just played this year
meaning 2016 though I think this is
going out in 2017 by the time you guys
see it at home but I want to show you
the game between Nakamura and mu Z Chuck
played in Gibraltar this year 2016 and
in the game he played the main move
Nakamura did which is rook to g1 the
alternative is [ __ ]
to d2 which also makes a lot of sense
I'm just going to prioritize development
and if you didn't take my Jeep on before
you're not going to take it now after
playing the move h6 because I still play
rook g1 and you'll get sort of the same
sort of positions so instead they
normally take and will sort of look at
these taking lines in the future and
here's one of the rare cases where in
this g4 line you can actually play the
move b5 it's important to actually go to
e2 because with the bishop coming to
this diagonal notice you did move your G
pawns so sometimes this guy actually
need some protection after E for we can
go back just to give you an example and
these lines normally you know black is
to play c5 and it's sort of similar to
lines we were looking at in the previous
weeks so we won't go too much into it
we'll just leave it here and say okay
very acceptable for black and in a lot
of these lines sometimes we ask
ourselves you know why did white play
them with g4 our goal as black is to try
to exploit it and make it look as silly
as possible
however in this game g1 this is the main
move and okay so if you Castle you know
you're going to run into moves like h4
g5 that would you sort of problematic
okay but II 5 and here Nakamura played a
very uncommon move is which is virtually
unplayed so more common is taking and if
you remember the structures we were
looking at last week and a lot of these
structures white has this familiar move
Knight to b5 attacking the bishop and
after the bishop goes back a move like
g5 so this is sort of the main line and
you know so you get and I think you know
blacks supposed to be doing just fine
here though it's it's always complicated
even when you know white gets no
advantage or anything it's still always
complicated so everything is always
worth playing for but uh in the game
just Bishop d2 I'm just going to Castle
alright make sense
efore
now I would love to install my knight on
that five if you would let me
so she said nope I know just H three and
he's kind of waiting I'm not developing
my bishop yet I'm not castling it's not
obvious what black should do so I'll
just wait I'll be patient for a second
black comes up with the plan a six b5 in
a lot of King's Indians that's sort of
the main plan but this game isn't a good
case for this style of play because it
just didn't really work out now white
we've got sort of a very good position
coming up this also is a good move
though okay she can move the bishop but
misplace the white rook first the rook
was better on g1 now f3 and here black
made an unfortunate blunder though it's
very hard to see why perhaps best is
Queen d7 just protecting the e4 square
again but instead this move a5
and again it's always about having the
more active pieces notice that you know
black still hasn't castled and castling
is kind of dangerous so okay we take
this makes a lot of sense b4
and they takes t5 so this is actually a
very powerful sacrifice and it's sort of
typical for these kinds of lines I'm
trying to bust open the center so here
you know a very powerful case for just
opening up the center taking advantage
of your lead here and development all
right and then just take back now if
here which was not played there's a lot
of good moves
I suppose good enough is Queeny for with
the idea that if you go here I take your
knight if you go here I take your rogue
but also very strong is another Knight
sacrifice yeah so this is this is sort
of a cause for alarm if I get to do all
of this because now if here you know I'm
going to play Bishop c4 one of these
rooks is coming to the F file this is
not going to be good for black so
there's all these powerful sacrifices in
the position so you can't even really
take oops in the game
Bishop g3 was played and here not come
where I actually could have taken on g6
again this is a very strong continuation
and that would have been nice to you
sank both your Knights for a couple of
bonds and you know this the center even
though sometimes it might look like a
Tetris piece it's actually gonna be
really strong and powerful moving
forward in the game okay but instead he
played a more cautious move way too
still just doing great with g1 I
returned Bishop c4 now I don't know if
she understood really White's threat it
looks like well I just protected my pawn
white actually has a sneaky threat here
and perhaps it was overlooked or perhaps
black just thought it was so bad there
was nothing to be done she went with
Bishop to a6 and now there's a killer
blow already so very unfortunate
so moved in Nakamura play in this
position d6
yeah that's is what was played okay I
take it Queen takes g6 yeah and now
white is just simply winning attack a
pinch piece defend a pin piece
threatened to remove the defender black
resigns so a very powerful game and it
sort of emphasizes one of the key things
in this you are looking at piece
sacrifices constantly it's more
important in all of these positions to
have the more active pieces and you want
to try to be the first to Castle and
start an attack and open up the center
even at the cost of a piece that's what
this game really shows us so yeah and so
just this idea this was all quite slow
a6 b5 and then it was just too much when
you played b4 here because we have this
very powerful sacrifice and Nakamura did
play it in the game so excellent that
guy's pretty good ok and there so
there's one move left right go ahead
d take c4 and so again there's a lot of
new people here so we'll we'll go over
this one more time it is sort of an you
know anti positional move you there was
a pawn in the center no it's over here
and just going to get taken but you did
give your knight this square and I can
go to d5 also now I'm ready to play a
move like 'if I've without having to
worry about you capturing on d5 first
and everything should be quite fine here
for black so that's why this is also a
very common way of playing and it would
be sort of remiss of me not to show a
sheer off game since it's the should she
rupture ball of attack so I want to show
the game shear off resume from my Orca
in 2004 so this might be the best so
good thing you saved the best for last
even though they're all so good this
should take c4 is the main move I do
want to just very briefly they'll talk
about them of g5
not as common but there's one idea
that's rather nice in this position it's
you can play a move here that you
probably wouldn't think about unless you
knew this position you can actually play
the move e5 which looks kind of strange
because aren't you blundering upon well
there are some tactical tricks here and
also again it's not always about the
pawns it's about having the more active
pieces but let's blunder for a second
let's take the way that we kind of want
to play what would black play now clean
a5 check found very quickly by some of
the youngest kids in the audience so you
can consider taking this way so better I
think a mean Bishop d2 is sort of the
main move if you must take you can at
least take this way and you are up a
pawn because now Queen a5 runs into
Knight to c3 just offend my knight but
here you can actually just castle and
this should be just fine for black yeah
I don't really know what you should do
here is white because you're you're
quite far behind in development so you
have to be a little bit worried in these
types of positions so you know g5 not a
very popular move so instead they take
here and now always you know if white
ever plays a move like g5 we can always
go to d5 so II five so again if g5 95 we
get a similar position so the stat
Bishop d2 we're going to castle so he
took and now we're getting closer to
taking on g4 so he attacks the bishop
everything is attacking g4 and here
black made a mistake so there's one way
that's really bad to take on g4 and
unfortunately black played that move so
let's see if you guys are good at
finding all the best moves but can you
find the worst way to take on g4 yeah
that's that's a lot harder it's a harder
task you guys are too good
okay why do you think that one source is
that because you saw it yeah so even at
night capture is better and then due to
the question mark exclamation was able
to deduce that taking with the bishop is
actually the worst and the reason is if
we trade these guys look at the f5
square so that night's going to go to f5
and white already gets a huge attack in
this game so first he played off four he
traded the bishops and Knight f5 so I'm
on your bishop I'm on your jeep on you
you could save your bishop angle here
but I'm going to Castle and just like
how are you I'm going to play Ritchie
one you know you can't really go there
because then it's sort of bad news also
when I Castle now I'm gonna have a rook
here someone to be threatening all sorts
of stuff on d6 what to do I guess we can
show one example if you Castle which was
not played I think I play here first
making like castle like the problem is
as soon as I ever Castle is to bat moves
for you I'm on this guy's you have to
worry about this guy then I'm bringing
this guy in this guy's going here so
there's all sorts of bad stuff that
could possibly happen it's going to get
a very very fast attack in the game
black tried to play clever move and this
move is okay that went to h4 because I
want to trade for that guy but now I
take on g7 okay so unsurprisingly he got
a rather big attack on that on the black
King here so nice attack you might think
we're just going to move it no we're
just going to castle because now if we
go here which is a little mistake we
have a strong move
94 so even though we gave up a piece
we're threatening Bishop to c3 skewering
the king and the rook and attacking d6 a
bunch of times so you can't actually
take so instead Knight to f2 was played
it seems nice enough
I'm going to win some more material but
now here black might want to think about
actually taking the night because the
knight is you know kind of scary but
white one here which is a big mistake
and now White has a winning position
believe it or not so first he just took
back and again you can't really take the
night because of Bishop c3 so we drop
that guy back know many ways to win but
he played f5
Queen b6 getting the Queen off the same
diet same file as the rook f6
you're just solidifying that guy there
but also creating sort of a net that
might be important later because it's
really squeezing the black King in there
okay we'll trade those guys
and when he went back late c5 so I'm
coming into d7
age six well let's just waste a move
just to sort of illustrate if here
there's like a very complicated mate
starting like with this this Knight f5 I
think so you're going to want to go here
this doesn't really work because of here
so you're threatening multiple mates so
black actually has to be really careful
so okay you didn't do that h6
so that in some line says King can run
away but this isn't going to be enough
to help them and this was great because
Europe found all the best moves and all
these positions he just played a
fantastic game
I think this move is really tough lots
of moves should win like I think either
Knight at-6 actually wins 97 might win
but he played the absolute best move
which I think would be really hard for
people to play here like gd6 yeah I'm
pretty sure either night here wins
pretty sure something like this is great
I guess Queen C for Queen b3 yes I think
something like this is dangerous you
want you want this guy so I think that
actually does win the game be played
Knight to f5 which seems weird you know
this awesome night you know boxing the
King out why would you want to trade
them well you can't really trade that's
part of the point because now I take
here and you know I have this threat on
your queen it's just not really easy to
deal with
so this is actually just quite strong
for white so like to not play there 97
97 I think you should probably take it
but he went here
took
and now you got to play one last nice
finishing move again there might be more
than one way to win here but we'll
finish the class with just this one last
exercise here
can you play like sheriff you want to
play the absolute best move because it's
it's matin a couple of you if you find
the right move here otherwise you can
win slowly but ninety five yeah much
better you saw it the origin sought way
before knows okay for the record let the
record show Arjun saw it before tennis
or at the same time okay so very good
both of you you found the finishing move
to this game and black resigned because
if here then here also if not here then
you know here and here
so if here rook d7 and nothing but
badness would just be a quick checkmate
so awesome I hope you guys enjoyed this
it's a very aggressive system it's very
fun to play as both sides if you like
this aggressive attacking chess that's
what the semi Slav is all about you both
sides have great chances to win it pays
to know your stuff in these lines so
we're going to get this tournament
started here in just a second so thanks
guys for for coming out we got a lot of
people here it was great
you